Consider our robot here that's
interacting with the world.
The first thing it sees is some state,
and as we've talked about already,
the thing to do now is to take that
state, go look in the Q table and
find the action that corresponds
to the maximum Q value.
And then take that action.
Once that action is taken,
that results in two new things.
One is a new state,
we call that S prime, and a reward.
All that information
comes into the robot, and
it needs to use that information
to update its Q table.
So as a consequence of this interaction
with the world, it's got an s,
an a, an s prime, and an r.
How does it take that information
to improve this Q table?
There are two main parts
to the update rule.
The first is, what is the old
value that we used to have?
And that's Q [s, a].
And what is our improved estimate?
And we want to blend them together.
And to combine them,
we introduce this new variable, alpha.
Alpha is the learning rate.
Alpha can take on any value from 0 to 1.
Usually, we use about 0.2.
And what that means is,
in our new improved version of Q,
which I indicate over here as Q prime,
it's a blend of alpha
times the improved estimate,
plus 1 minus alpha of the old value.
So larger values of alpha cause
us to learn more quickly,
lower values of alpha cause
the learning to be more slow.
So a low value of alpha, for instance,
means that in this update rule,
the previous value for
Q of sa is more strongly preserved.
So stretching it out
a little bit more detail.
Again we have here,
our current value for the Q at s,a,
plus alpha times the immediate reward,
plus gamma times later rewards.
Now we're introducing gamma here, so I
promise there's only two new parameters
here that you have to worry about.
What gamma is is the discount rate.
And similar to alpha,
gamma usually ranges from 0 to 1.
A low value of gamma means that
we value later rewards less.
Remember the discount rate when
we were talking about bonds?
Same thing.
A low value of gamma equates to
essentially a high discount rate.
The high value of gamma,
in other words a gamma near 1,
means that we value later
rewards very significantly.
If we were to use 1.0, that means
a reward 20 steps in the future
is worth just as much
as a reward right now.
Now, we have to expand this component
here in a little bit more detail.
This next part here is a little
bit tricky, but don't worry,
we're going to step
through it step by step.
This component represents our
future discounted rewards.
In other words, we end up in state
s prime, and from then on out,
we're going to act optimally, or
at least, the best that we know how to.
And the question is,
what is the value of those future
rewards if we reach state S prime and
we act appropriately?
Well, it is simply that Q value, but
we have to find out what the action
is that we would have taken, so that
we can reference the Q table properly.
So, If we're in state s prime,
the action that
we would take that would maximize
our future reward is argmax a prime,
so a prime is the next action
that we're going to take.
With regard to Q, s prime, a prime.
So we're going to find
that best a prime,
that best action, that maximizes
the value when we're in that state.
So this collapses just to a prime, and
then we look up the Q table value for
Q s prime, a prime.
So that allows us to bring
it all together now.
So our update rule is the following.
Our new Q value in state s,
action a is that
old value multiplied by 1 minus alpha.
So depending on how large alpha is,
we valued that old value more or
less, plus alpha times
our new best estimate.
And our new best estimate is,
again, our immediate reward,
plus the discounted reward for
all of our future actions.
And that's it.
This is the equation you need
to know to implement Q learning.